alles klar ein kluger so viele abos hat
man luca was ist das überhaupt ein
bekloppter name ich komme eine kamera
geboxt herzlich willkommen wie heute zu
einem video auf dass er viele gewartet
haben es ist nämlich mein zweiter vor
einigen tagen ist das hier passiert und
da ich eigentlich gar keine kooperation
von anderen youtuber mache ich mir
gedacht heute in meinem 2 millionen
abonnenten special frage ich einfach mal
ein paar leute ob sie welche worte haben
mich haben irgendwie gratulieren möchte
da kommen sie mein heutiges video okay
ich sehe es roadster erste youtuber sehr
gut
vielleicht fallen ja andere was da nicht
ob ich mal für computer
ja genau zu meinen zwei millionen hat
sich sicher gefragt ob du mir irgendwas
aufnehmen kannst und wir müssen mit mir
wenn ich meine millionen saps da kann
ich ja auch nichts für möchte mir sonst
noch was sagen okay also vielleicht man
die ersten mal eine einblendung jetzt
nicht so so schön aber ich schaue was
bei der nächsten wahl nächste
einblendung war von stefan gehrig
ich habe mal was er mir geschickt hat
wisse dass es gehört keiner interessiert
sich für dich also der name sagt
irgendwie gar nichts
luca ja sag mir mal glücklich auf der
youtube startseite gesehen acht der typ
du weißt ich eigentlich nicht so ne also
die videos nicht scheint und ich bin
jetzt nur mitmachen ein bisschen abos
abzustauben
das ist ja super klasse echt luca ruch
zugesandt wurde sagt irgendwas nettes
der macht der typ von musical uci wollt
ihr mich verarschen aber mal schauen was
die juso gesagt zwei millionen menschen
folgen von craft konkret da gucken zwei
millionen leute folgen hier konkret ich
weiß nicht wieso ich sage euch dann echt
so dass er sich wuttke hart getroffen
von den einsendungen die ich bekommen
habe ich dazu jetzt hab ich doch dass du
dich nicht unverdient da sind content
ist ein scheiße ok dann will ich euch
die nächste person die mir was geschickt
hat ist costa der ist eigentlich ein
alter kerl also ich schau mal was er mir
geschickt das vielleicht mustert mich
dass jetzt ein bisschen auch ich habe
nie verstanden warum er bei der zweiten
staffel gleich dabei war ich dachte da
geht's um die guten youtube als hatte
ich gesagt überhitzung die guten youtube
weitere deutsche youtuber 2 million
abonnenten erreicht okay dass meine
kumpels apple und ich könnte schwören
der haut irgendwas letztes raus schön
wenn jux mit luca 2000 jahre später
vielleicht habe keine bilder zusammen
ich soll für die video botschaft
aufnehmen ein scheiß mache ich okay dass
das land seine hörer frick das war echt
lukla ist nicht der typ da irgendwie
zwei millionen abonnenten hat weil er
jedes mal den trend ist und ein tolles
fix vergeben zeigen muss was hab ich
wieder was sage ich bin raus
ich war noch nie in den trend was mache
ich denn hier nun endlich weil er ein
bisschen positiver entwicklung luke rwe
sluka verschießt dass mahler das finde
ich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen traurig
waren schon in so vielen gemeinsamen
gaming projekten aber hallo mein name
ist lokal ich bin 20 jahre alt und jetzt
kennst du mich ja zwei millionen
abonnenten
ich bin verstört noch kurz raus leute ok
hat nichts gebracht dieser luca der
touch antwort wir zusammen feiern
sondern
der kabel nicht also ich kenne ich gar
nicht lena selbst von dir hätte ich
gedacht ist als zwei millionen verkauft
das denn
gegeben
saufen und raufen die gehabt ihm
aufgekommen und den leuten gesagt
sie gewannen wir irgendwie auch brütet
geeignet diese jüngere auf deutschland
ist auch südafrika wie nutzer von de
luca der computer hat zwei millionen
abonnenten 2 oder wurden zwei millionen
abonnenten scheiße scheiße trotz zweier
abonnenten oder hat aber einen
rausgehauen er klar sagte dazu jetzt
nämlich so gar nicht nur dennis und ben
isa und hauke hoch mein leben ist vorbei
das was sie von dem video meine damen
und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
vielleicht trotzdem ein bisschen
gefallen ich weiß es dass jetzt kein
krasses special bar wo ich jetzt einen
song raus gehauen hat oder ein film
wurde es wieder wurde ein neues buch aus
ghana oder so was in die richtung die
ich feiere halt einfach abonnenten
zahlen
ich sollte mir scheiß egal ob 32
millionen oder 1000 steht deswegen habe
ich mir trotzdem gedacht okay ich frage
einfach mal ein paar youtube optimiert
witzigen tipps zusammenstellen können
und kurz darauf irgend etwas witziges
vielleicht war es auch gar nicht witzig
ich wollte nur irgendwas machen bevor
ich wieder mal gar nichts mal
verweigerte eine million nichts gemacht
und deswegen würde ich sagen beende ich
das video jetzt einfach mal mit dem
schlusswort wir haben hier in oberhausen
scheiße und war antwortet mir doch jetzt
wird ihr mal diese frage in den
kommentaren warum abonniert ihr meine
chance die ich hier hochladen das würde
mich echt mal interessieren wie das
überhaupt mit mehr als zwei millionen
leute machen konnten als rechtsmittel
die kommentare mit den fingern anders
wieder chips